[Music]
according to the centers for disease
control and prevention more than six and
a half
million americans have now received
their first dose of the vaccine against
the coronavirus
it's a number that will be growing every
day though it's well behind what public
health experts
had been hoping to see along with
manufacturing and distribution issues
public health officials are concerned
about millions of americans
who are resistant to taking the vaccine
to address
that some of those officials are shining
a light
not just on the science behind the shots
but on the scientists who help
bring the vaccines to fruition
when the president paid a visit to the
national institutes of health last march
the leads at the vaccine research center
explain their life-saving mission
why shake proteins that will bind the
key to it
a 34 year old doctor named kismikia
corbett
i was just there telling the task force
about the work that we've been doing two
weeks later
dr corbett's team began the first stage
of clinical trials
we have taken a lot of the knowledge
that we have gained over the last six
years
and applied it to a fairly revolutionary
vaccine
platform in collaboration with moderna
that vaccine rolled out within 10 months
the vaccine teaches the body how to fend
off a virus
because it teaches the body how to look
for the virus
by basically just showing the body the
spike protein
of the virus the body then says oh we've
seen this protein before
let's go fight against it that's how it
works for a lot of people
seeing you as the person who is part of
this process
there's there's a trust factor to be
honest
i didn't realize the level of impact
that my visibility might have i do my
work because
i love my work dr corbett's interest in
science
began at an early age but one
opportunity made a key difference
she attended the university of maryland
baltimore county
as a meyerhoff scholar an aggressive
program that mentors minorities and
women in science
graduates include surgeon general jerome
adams
was she someone who's going to make it
all along she was definitely going to
make it in life
dr freeman rabowski has been president
there for nearly 30 years
she had strong science background but
she also was very comfortable with
people
we need more scientists who can connect
to people she could do that when she was
17 easily
what we do at umbc is to support
students
of color black but also students in
general
to make sure they make it in science
only 18 percent of
all students graduate with a stem degree
according to the national
center for education statistics around 2
percent
are black it's important for those
people to see people looking like them
like themselves who can be involved if
it's about women or it's about blacks
because it shows that you've got people
who understand what you've gone through
dr corbett and i have worked together
for maybe
15 or 16 years since she was in high
school dr barney grahams
not only corbett's mentor he's her boss
when you recognize somebody has special
qualities
you need to do things that can keep
those other things out of the way and
and avoid some of the dismissiveness
that often happens
not only to minority people but to women
and historically that bias strikes not
just professionals in the field
but those that they serve let's talk
about the impediments to the trust
i grew up in birmingham all of my life
i was hearing about the tuskegee study
the federally sanctioned tuskegee
experiment sought to examine the
long-term effects of civilis
by letting infected black men go
untreated with no regard to the
suffering it caused
how do you feel about being used as a
guinea pig
well i thought once it was pretty rough
another example the special cells of
baltimore cancer patient henrietta lacks
were taken without her explicit
permission
and were subsequently used in billions
of dollars worth of medical research
without compensation there are many
other examples
of supposedly objective scientists
who were caring about everyone who
valued people of color
less it's a painful truth and this is
what's significant when i say
cozmica corbett is from a small town in
north carolina a young woman of faith
who understands the socio-cultural
issues that we face
who knows what racism means she gets all
of that
what's your message to people who are
hesitant
to take this vaccine number one is that
i get it
number two is that to really take
advantage
of the level of transparency that
we are attempting even i haven't even
seen before
such as fda hearings and briefings
being broadcast online and data coming
out
almost instantly and to try and address
them and in one of those webinars
fully dr anthony fauci gave her a ton
of credit the vaccine that you're going
to be taking was developed by an
african-american woman
and that is just a fact i mean that is a
fact a fact
offering illumination to those often
left
in the dark she cannot be a hidden
figure
she cannot be a hidden figure she needs
to be in
textbooks little girls need to see her
of all races
this is what's possible she's not a
hidden figure now
yeah no she's not and it's just it is a
testament to the work of
dr rabowski and others like dr graham
her boss
who pushed and also moved out
barriers in her way so she could have
that opportunity yeah yeah and look at
all of us benefiting now from it i was
gonna say the only way you can undo all
those years of damage
is to start right now and start moving
those to the side put her in the
forefront and try to change minds
and there are others out there just like
her of all races great you want to give
them all a big round of applause okay
good stuff michelle